first of all the black truck slams into
the fence then the Army comes
some of the men in the truck appear to
have guns the soldiers pull them out
kicked them then the soldiers appeared
to defend themselves from another threat
off camera
and that is when they shoot their
prisoners
this is happening in Nuevo Laredo one of
the hottest spots in Mexico for cartel
violence
caught on a local CCTV camera date
stamped 18th of May three weeks ago but
the shooting of the prisoners is not
where it ends after that one of the
soldiers plants weapons on the Fallen
men careful to use what looks to be a
red flag to avoid getting his prints on
the guns one soldier even appears to
take up the handcuffs they put on a man
to make it look like he hadn't been
arrested before being shot
the videos caused a lot of questions
here in Mexico
this is what the Army's been accused of
so many times over the last few years in
Mexico since it's been brought in to
fight organized crime extrajudicial
killings the flagrant violation of
citizens rights but it's the first time
that it's been caught so nakedly so
openly in front of the camera the
question now is will there be
consequences especially going up the
ranks
it seems that there were unlawful
killings and that can't be allowed
we're not the same as the past
governments when there is an abuse in
excess a violation of Human Rights there
has to be punishment of those
responsible and that's already started
the Army said in a statement that it's
cooperating with the Attorney General's
office in the investigation and that
there's no impunity
but Justin whoever Laredo itself this is
at least the second case of alleged
unlawful Army killings this year after
right groups claimed that soldiers shot
five unarmed men in a vehicle this
February
this incident will almost certainly not
stop the Army's heavy involvement in
Security in Mexico we're a fully
functional National Police Force capable
of stopping powerful criminals seems as
far away as ever
Mexico City